CHARGE PEOPLE, NOT THAT YOU CAN
CHARGE A SITTING PRESIDENT, AND
THE PRESIDENT HAS EVERY RIGHT TO
FIRE ANYBODY WANTS, FOR THE
THOUGHTS THEY HAVE IN THEIR HEAD
FOR A JOINING US NOW, FORMER
WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY
SEAN SPICER, "THE HILL"'S JOE
CONCHA, FORMER PRESIDENT OF THE
NATIONAL CORRESPONDENTS
ASSOCIATION, FOX NEWS CHIEF
NATIONAL CORRESPONDENT,
ED HENRY.
LET'S GO WITH YOU, SEAN SPICER.
YOU KNOW, IT IS FASCINATING IF
ANYONE EVER LEAKED ANY OF THIS
FROM ANY SPECIAL COUNSEL, AND TO
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," ANOTHER
ANONYMOUS SOURCE, IT WOULD BE
AGAINST A DEMOCRAT, YOU AND I
BOTH KNOW, THERE WOULD BE SUCH
AN OUTCRY IN THE COUNTRY ABOUT
THAT.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I THINK THAT WHAT YOU ARE SEEING
NOW IS DEFINITELY CONCERNING.
I UNDERSTAND WHY THE PRESIDENT
WANTS TO GET THIS WRAPPED UP.
WE'VE SEEN THIS GO OVER AND OVER
AGAIN FOR THE BETTER PART OF THE
YEAR, NO EVIDENCE HAS COME
FORWARD, EVERYTHING GETS LEAKED
OUT, IT'S ABOUT TIME THAT THEY
FISH OR CUT BAIT.
THE PRESIDENT AND THE
WHITE HOUSE HAVE BEEN VERY
FORTHCOMING WITH INDIVIDUALS
INFORMATION AND IT'S ABOUT TIME
THAT WE EITHER WRAP THIS THING
UP OR WE ALLOW THE PRESIDENT --
THIS PRESIDENT IS DOING GREAT
THINGS AND HAS TO MOVE ON ON THE
AGENDA IN THIS COUNTRY.
>> Sean: WHAT WAS YOUR
OPINIONS OF MR. COMEY?
WHAT IS A MATTER?
YOU CAN FIRE HIM FOR ANY REASON,
JOE CONCHA.
>> I THINK WE SEE, SEAN, WITH
THE BEHAVIOR OF JAMES COMEY ON
THE BOOK TO HER, GETTING
PERSONAL BY THE PRESIDENT, IF
YOU LOOK AT KELLYANNE BRENNAN'SA
YOU LOOK AT KELLYANNE BRENNAN'ST
YOU LOOK AT KELLYANNE BRENNAN'SI
YOU LOOK AT KELLYANNE BRENNAN'SR
YOU LOOK AT KELLYANNE BRENNAN'SA
YOU LOOK AT KELLYANNE BRENNAN'SC
YOU LOOK AT KELLYANNE BRENNAN'SU
YOU LOOK AT KELLYANNE BRENNAN'ST
YOU LOOK AT KELLYANNE BRENNAN'S
YOU LOOK AT KELLYANNE BRENNAN'SO
YOU LOOK AT KELLYANNE BRENNAN'SU
SEE A VITRIOLIC
PERSON ON THERE, IT IS HARD TO
BELIEVE THAT WHEN HE WAS RUNNING
THE CIA, THAT HE ACTUALLY WAS
ABLE TO SEPARATE ALL OF THOSE
FEELINGS AND DO HIS JOB WITHOUT
THAT SORT OF PARTISAN THINKING.
OBVIOUSLY, CLAPPER, NOW I SEE
CONTRIBUTOR, SAME THING.
I THINK THIS IS VERY DISTURBING
THAT YOU HAVE ALL OF THESE TOP
OFFICIALS ENGAGING IN PARTISAN
BEHAVIOR AND AS FURTHER LEAKS, I
MEAN, WE KEEP HEARING THAT
MUELLER IS RUNNING A
STRAIGHTFORWARD, CLEAN
INVESTIGATION, THEN HOW DOES
THAT GET INTO THE PAGES OF
"THE NEW YORK TIMES"?
I WOULD LOVE TO KNOW.
>> Sean: WHEN YOU APPOINT
ANDREW WEISSMANN, WHO WITHHELD
EXCULPATORY EVIDENCE TWICE, BUT
FOUR MERRILL EXECUTIVES IN JAIL
FOR A YEAR, OVERTURNED BY THE
FIFTH CIRCUIT, AND PUT TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF ANDERSON ACCOUNTING
WORKERS OUT OF WORK AND BLOW
EVERYTHING AND GET APPOINTED
BY MUELLER, EDDIE OUGHT TO TELL
YOU EVERYTHING YOU NEED TO KNOW.
ED HENRY, QUICK QUESTION ON THE
CORRESPONDENTS DINNER.
WHY WOULD PRESIDENT TRUMP EVER
GO?